[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
emmanuel macron et donc le huitième
président de la vème république à 39 ans
l'ancien ministre de l'économie a réussi
son pari à la tête de son mouvement en
marche lancé il y a un an une entrée sur
l'esplanade du louvre où il a fêté sa
victoire sur les notes de l'hymne à la
joie de beethoven l'hymne européen donc
un score historiquement haut 66,10 %
contre marine le pen à 33,90 un scrutin
marqué par une abstention historique et
une explosion du vote blanc et nul et le
front national double quasiment son
score de 2002 lorsque jean-marie le pen
était face à jacques chirac et
comptabilise près de 11 millions de voix
émission spéciale cette semaine comment
cette élection est elle perçue depuis le
parlement européen
ici à bruxelles qu'attend-t-on
d'emmanuel macro pour réformer l'europe
en france et donc ici au sein de ce
parlement pour en débattre j'ai le
plaisir de recevoir
evelyne gebhardt bonjour un jour vous
êtes député socialiste allemande
bienvenue à vous à côté de vous vous
avez claude rolin vous vous êtes membre
du ppe donc vous êtes belge bienvenue à
vous en face de vous l ouest orthez où
vous êtes espagnol et député vert
bienvenus première réaction peut-être
ernest urtasun
c'est un soulagement de voir emmanuel
macron et lui c'est un soulagement de ne
pas avoir marine le pen à l'elysée sur
ça je pense que c'est la bonne nouvelle
de dimanche
après on s'inquiète des politiques que
mano macron venait ça c'est très clair
je pense non plus qu'il ya un risque
d'entrer dans une période assez laide
d'instabilité politique en france parce
que bon c'est pas c'est pas sûr que mois
de juin emmanuel macron pu s'assurer une
majorité l'assemblée pour faire passer
toutes ces réformes en plus sur l'agenda
très néo libéral va sans doute rencontré
beaucoup de résistance en france donc je
pense que là il va il va y avoir on va
rentrer et social oui oui je pense sans
doute et en plus on connaît un petit peu
la capacité heureusement de mobilisation
des syndicats français de la fonction
publique donc là on va voir ça bon ça
d'un côté après sur l'europe
je pense que manuel macron
a pour le moment à annoncer des bonnes
intentions c'est à dire la réforme de la
zone euro à avancer vers mais je pense
qu'on va dans la bonne direction le seul
problème c'est que du côté allemand on a
déjà entendu le nein alors est-ce qu'il
va se retrouver sur les bons blocs est
bon on va voir ça dans les prochains
jours
claude rolin l'automne social en france
sur les réformes des manuels macron
c'est peut-être ce à quoi il faut
s'attendre
je ne sais pas on va voir on va voir
entrer qu'à manche à s'étonner de voir
la réaction des organisations syndicales
françaises j'entends d'une part le
discours d'une partie de la cgt
j'entends aussi le discours de la cfdt
qui dit simplement mais nous allons voir
ce que monsieur macron va décider et
nous allons nous faire entendre ils vont
devoir négocier et je pense que c'est
très bien en tous les cas de ce que j'ai
vu de monsieur macron j'ai plutôt le
sentiment qui alla quelqu'un qui est
intelligent et je pense que
l'intelligence doit conduire à des
dossiers avec les partenaires sociaux
evelyne gebhardt cette entrée sur
l'esplanade du louvre sur les notes de
l'hymne à la joie c'était quand même un
ouf de soulagement pour les européens
ici de voir à quel point l'europe
finalement a été adoubé dans ce scrutin
oui bien sûr c'est un soulagement et je
suis très heureuse que les une grande
majorité des français est bien dit
clairement oui à l'europe parce que
c'est ça qui a été fait en france mais
non aussi ah oui on s'est parlé et nous
et non au nationalisme populisme et je
pense que ça c'est quand même une
réponse très très positive il ne faut
pas être d'accord avec tout ce que
monsieur mac on veut faire ça c'est
évident et je pense comme vous il est
temps il est intelligent il va parler
avec les syndicats il va faire en sorte
je l'espère c'est ce qu'il a dit du
moins travailler à faire à créer des
emplois surtout pour les jeunes je pense
que ça c'est la réponse la plus
imminente à faire en france parce que
c'est la base
en fait des débuts du succès de madame
le pen parce qu'il faut bien voir que 11
millions de voir certaines cet énorme
éléments conseilleront tenir montée nous
ne pouvons pas dire nous continuons à
faire à faire comme j'ai maintenant elle
en europe ça ne va pas à l'image de lyon
coeur et de sa commission de la dernière
chance et peut-être aussi le
de la dernière chance si on ne veut pas
voir l'extrême droite au pouvoir en
france en 2022 claude rolin il faut être
attentif aussi j'ai des sentiments en
regardant la tv française en lisant les
des hebdos en france qui est un peu un
défaut français si je peux me permettre
l'expression cette attente l'homme ou la
femme providentiel qui est un peu notre
condition les sociétés commerciales ça
y'a l'élection d'un président le
président va construire va constituer
son parlement
il va devoir son gouvernement plus tôt
il va devoir le faire très rapidement en
fonction du résultat des élections
législatives je voulais simplement dire
moi je pense que c'est très clair que 1
mais une des grandes raisons pour les
coins pour lesquels le quinquennat de
françois hollande a échoué a été
l'incapacité de réformes et l'europe et
particulièrement la zone euro et là je
pense que c'est un des grands enjeux
pour voir si le quinquennat meubles
monsieur macron va vendre et réussit pas
réussir ou pas alors il ya quelque chose
de très important si monsieur macro met
sur la table on va voir des réformes
raisonnable de la zone euro que tout le
monde attend c'est très important que de
l'extérieur ils reçoivent un certain
soutien sur ce je pense surtout j'en ai
beaucoup parlé à mes collègues des verts
allemands et ben on a aussi eu vent de
la gauche allemande ici je pense qu'il
nous faut aussi des voix en allemagne et
je comprends maintenant il ya eu hier
l'élection et c'est très compliqué parce
que nous sommes en compagnie de marquer
certaines positions ça c'est
compréhensible mais il nous faut aussi
des voix qui soutiennent ces deux lignes
parce que s'ils restent isolés comme
monsieur hollande a été là vraiment on
va avoir un risque d chaumont de son
briquet da est alors un risque que
marine le pen gagne la prochaine
élection effectivement alors à l'instar
de ce qu'on peut entendre donc dans vos
réactions les journaux européens aussi
un an
pousser un ouf de soulagement et c'est
donc la une du taz notamment des
thagaste sight en allemagne alors el
país qui indique en fait que la france a
créé la déroute du radicalisme le temps
parle de son côté de la génération
macron le daily telegraph parle de
nouvel espoir qui va mettre un petit peu
de nuages sur le break site
le guardian donc macron qui a gagné la
présidence française mais la france
reste profondément divisé le soir qui
indique que pour mac rond tout commence
alors c'est quoi en fait l'enjeu
aujourd'hui on parlait justement de ces
fractures françaises
le chômage des jeunes et c'est le gros
des réformes française a mené
aujourd'hui c'est quoi peut-être claude
rolin pour moi clairement c'est l'emploi
c'est l'emploi et en particulier
l'emploi des jeunes mais on un chômage
qui fait mal qui est en train de
disloquer nos sociétés c'est aussi l
europe c est un combat combat européen
c'est aussi un combat par rapport à la
cohésion
nous devons construire plus de cohésion
dans nos sociétés plus de cohésion à
luttant contre les inégalités mais aussi
plus de cohésion territoriale
on vend france quand je regarde les
cartes du vote fn eh bien il correspond
et les freins car derrière région où les
gens se sentent à tort ou à raison mais
les gens se sent délaissée linke martin
est souvent représenté comme étant
potentiellement le futur gerhard
schröder français emmanuel macron
gerhard schröder donc l'ancien
chancelier socialiste qui a un petit peu
le permis à l'allemagne de ceux de
redevenir compétitive mais qui a aussi
cassé un petit peu socialement les
classes et plus les plus précarisés est
ce que c'est un peu un risque bien sûr
qu'il ya un risque en effet choix d'or a
fait quelques réformes qui étaient très
positifs pour l'économie allemande
mais en même temps dans certains
domaines justement sur la précarisation
du travail
là il ya eu des erreurs qui ont été
faites donc ce que je n'espère que macro
on va faire ce qu'il va apprendre ce qui
s'est passé en allemagne de reprendre ce
qui a été positif mais en même temps de
faire attention à ne pas précarisés de
travail parce que c'est ça qui qui nous
agacent est presque en tant que social
démocrate
en allemagne aussi de voir que le
travail n'est plus vraiment la base de
deux d'aider des gens pour leur avenir
est donc là il faut faire très attention
à donner les bonnes réponses ne pas
copier entièrement ce qui a été fait en
allemagne ce crétin ce serait un
problème
oui effectivement et c'est d'ailleurs la
majorité enfin la corrélation avec les
socialistes qui a réintroduit la
question du salaire minimum par exemple
comme par exemple dans notre programme
social démocrate pour les élections au
mois de septembre nous remet thomas
martin schmid met en cause un certain
nombre de ses réformes qui ont été
faites sous schröder et de dire là nous
voyons les effets négatifs pour les
travailleurs ça nous devons leur a
d'ailleurs rendu à ses sentiments
alors il ya eu toute une série de tweets
de félicitations au niveau européen
quelques-uns avec emmanuel macron donc
michel barnier avec emmanuel macron la
france confirme clairement son
engagement dans l'union européenne et
pour l'euro il ya tant à faire ensemble
nigel farrage dans un autre genre
emmanuel macron offre cinq ans de plus
des chèques de pouvoir à l'union
européenne et de frontières ouvertes si
marine le pen continue comme ça elle
peut gagner en 2022 on le disait tout à
l'heure
mariano rajoy félicitations emmanuel
macron nouveau président français
travaillons français espagne pour une
europe stable prospère plus intégré
le président tajani le président du
parlement européen l'a félicité
également il l'appelle en fait à venir
s'adresser aux parlementaires européens
rapidement donald trump également il a
été donc de son de son twitt de
félicitations disant je suis impatient
de travailler avec lui donald de tous qu
également et enfin garde builder bien
jouer marine le pen des millions aux
patriots ont voté pour toi tu gagneras
la prochaine fois tout comme moi
alors justement quelques réactions qui
ont été suivies aussi donc de
déclarations notamment dans gala merkel
et de jean claude juncker or et écoute
ce travail nous coordonnons rapprocher
avant sont partout où cela est possible
d'un pari commun pour le bien de nous
deux pays mais aussi pour le bien de
l'europe et de la north sinful euros
parce que non et c'est exactement
l'esprit que j'espère et qui sera
présent je le crois dans le travail en
cotisant m'embête macro fait nouveau
c'est un bon résultat pour la france
j'espère que le nouveau président serin
capable de réconcilier une france
divisée en deux c'est plus que
nécessaire et c'est une bonne nouvelle
pour l'europe car le programme du
président macron était un programme 13
européen elle donc je suis très heureux
de ce résultat
alors viens d'entendre le président de
la commission mais qui ne s'est pas
contenté de féliciter emmanuel macron il
ne lui a laissé aucun l'étape grâce et
la prévenue en écoute du franc les
français dépensent trop d'argent et il
le dépense ou mauvais endroit les
français consacrent entre 53 et 57 pour
cent de leur produit intérieur brut
alors budget public et compte tenu du
niveau relativement élevé de la dette
cela ne peut pas fonctionner dans la
durée alors r la tentation de votre
réaction elle y va un peu fort car jean
claude juncker aucun état de grâce est
tout de suite c'est la france doit
revenir en fait dans l'est l'une des du
traité budgétaire européen et dans la
lune des déficits qu'on accepte sinon
attention mais écoutez moi moi moi moi
je peux vous dire tout d'abord les pays
qui ont connu un petit peu de croissance
dans la dernière année comme le mien par
exemple ils ont connu une certaine
croissance parce qu'ils ont pas respecté
le nom budgétaires européennes qui ont
démontré dans cette crise qui sont
inapplicables qu'on y a des c'est vrai
posant de déficit c'est n'importe quoi
quand elle l'a contraint au chômage et
un chômage à 20% contre la contrainte à
une crise comme lumière ou le pipe a
chuté de plus de 15% c'est absolument
impair de la rue mais bien sûr et tout
le monde l'a fait en plus on ne
respectons pas et la commission en plus
aller se faire dans certains pays comme
le mien parce que le 3% et d' absolument
ingérable
mais toute façon je me fais pas non plus
sauver l'économie espagnole faire que
l'économie espagnole est pas l'économie
grecque m'ont plu non mais bien sûr mais
de toute façon moi je veux dire que ces
propos deux jours après les élections et
vous n'essayez pas d'abord à monsieur
jonckheere de dire alors président de la
république française qui doit comment il
doit comment il doit gérer les ces
réformes laisser monsieur macro proposés
et puis on va en tout cas ce que je
pense que monsieur juncker n'est pas le
mieux placé pour faire des
recommandations sur des réformes
nationales
après avoir fait tous les taxes ruling
qu'il a fait quand il était ministre de
finances au luxembourg ça c'est
l'exemple à ne pas suivre de tout ça
c'est sans doute comme ça un claude
rolin jean claude juncker c'est un peu
le meilleur ennemi finalement des gens
qui détestent l'europe c'est la figure
même en fait de ce qu'il ne faut pas
faire je n'irai pas jusque là parce que
je pense qu'il faut bien longtemps ce
qu'il a dit je pense qu'il a fait une
erreur en tous les cas je suis
absolument pas d'accord dans cette
déclaration je pense que d'ailleurs la
commission devrait apprendre est
globalement plus simple et plus modestes
et accompagner les états ceci étant dit
je pense qu'effectivement il y à des
réformes en france à faire il y à une
meilleure orientation des moyens publics
qui doit être fait faux pas va faire de
l'endettement pour faire de
l'endettement
ce qu'il faut c'est faire en sorte que
les moyens publics les moyens de la
collectivité soit orientée vers
l'objectif essentiel
créée voilà tout à fait mais la
structure de l'état attention si quand
on parle de structures de l'état
il ya des dépenses publiques qui sont
tout à fait pertinente il ya des
défenses public qui le sont moins
il faut faire des choix à l'intérieur
mais moi je suis absolument pas
dogmatique contre la dépense est
d'ailleurs bien les assurés 3% pour vous
c'est quelque chose et 3% ne veulent
rien dire ce qu'il faut ce n'est pas
augmenter le niveau d'endettement parce
que nous savons qu en augmentant le
niveau d'endettement ont créé des dettes
pour les générations futures dettes
refinancées rentrée d'août on a d'autres
types de dettes qui sont notamment des
dettes en termes d'environnement thèmes
de société aussi
il faut en tenir compte mais donc il
faut avoir une certaine souplesse
tournant tout en ayant une rigueur il
faut être
efficace j'ai le sentiment que monsieur
monsieur macron peut y parvenir
en tous les cas moi ce que je souhaite
c'est qu'il ya un axe effectivement
franco allemand il est important il est
structurant dans l'union européenne qui
puisse se construire qu'ils puissent
effectivement peser pour que nous ayons
des politiques plus qu'ils rencontrent
plus latente des citoyens paient alors
justement là-dessus on a fait un petit
peu un tour des propositions des manuels
macron sur la question européenne
c'est ça nous met au rose roll douglas
qui nous en parle
je suis le candidat d'une france forte
dans une europe qui protège c'est par
ces mots qu emmanuel macron a donné sa
vision de l'union européenne lors du
débat d'entre deux tours l'ancien
ministre a été l'un des seuls candidats
à mener une campagne pro européenne le
candidat dans marche a présenté sa
feuille de route qu'il entend conduire
avec les états membres de l'union
européenne pour les 5 à 10 années à
venir
le nouveau locataire de l'elysée portent
le projet inédit d'une souveraineté
européenne pour redorer le blason de
l'union son objectif rendent leur a plus
fortes sont toutefois refonder les
institutions mais en modifiant les
processus de décision vers une union à
plusieurs vitesses le nouveau président
français entend lancer dans toute
l'union européenne des conventions
démocratique
il propose aussi de créer un budget pour
la zone euro ainsi qu'un poste de
ministre de l'économie et des finances
de la zone euro en matière de libre
échange
emmanuel macron est prêt à reconsidérer
sa position initialement favorable sur
le ceta accord contesté entre l'union
européenne et le canada
il a récemment premier de s'appuyer sur
les conclusions d'une commission
d'experts pour trancher sur la question
et revoir le traité il porte le projet
d'un bail européenne actes l'enjeu
réserver l'accès aux marchés publics
européens à certaines entreprises qui
localise la moitié de leur production en
europe le leader dans marche suggère
aussi un contrôle des investissements
étrangers en europe dans les secteurs
stratégiques salaire minimum couverture
santé assurance chômage
il souhaite également consolider les
droits sociaux européens
question sécurité il envisage un
renforcement des frontières extérieures
et une meilleure gestion des flux
migratoires sur le continent la crise
des réfugiés devrait être résorbée grâce
à l'aide au développement dans les pays
d'origine et une politique d'asile comme
une bonne nouvelle pour la jeunesse
européenne
emmanuel macron plaide pour un programme
erasmus généralisée en faveur d'une
mobilité plus large
[Musique]
evelyne gebhardt quand vous entendez en
fait c'est grande idée d' emmanuel
macron notamment sur la réforme de la
zone euro lui devint doter la zone euro
d'un budget d'un ministre de l'économie
permanent finalement c'est ce que le
porte le parlement européen depuis pas
mal de temps
donc oui c'est dans la ligne ce sont des
idées que l'on peut vraiment mettre sur
la table et que l'on peut discuter et je
peux je pense qu'on doit aussi remettre
en cause la politique d'austérité
dès qu'elle est propagée dans le nine
des dons en salle est mal avec moi mais
je pense que c'est absolument nécessaire
parce que nous devons faire en sorte que
l'économie dans les états soit remis sur
les rails
là où ce n'est plus le cas pour pour
pourra rencontrer le chômage donc il
faut prendre des aspects très différents
de la politique dans l'union européenne
pour remettre vraiment ça dans une voix
vraiment positive est ce que vous allez
réussir à convaincre madame merkel
sienne spatiaux de pouvoir convaincre
madame merkel
mais je ne suis pas dans le même parti
que madame merkel est justement ce
moment mais s'il cette grande coalition
continue il va falloir aussi infléchir
un peu la position et la tendance
c'est pour ça que martin schulz en ce
moment est en train de faire campagne en
allemagne pour devenir le prochain
chancelier et alors là nous aurons une
autre situation dans un alignement des
planètes sa part été élu pour réformer
l'europe et que claude rolin c'est ça
l'enjeu c'est de recréer en fait de
l'investissement de faire en sorte qu on
démocratise aussi l'union européenne
pour recréer du lien avec les citoyens
mais quand j'entends ce qui vient d'être
dit du programme de monsieur mettront
par rapport à l'union européenne
je signe et je vote e sens sans la
moindre hésitation
c'est effectivement la ligne qu'il faut
suivre c'est à ça qu'il faut pas revenir
et on voit clairement les problèmes que
nous avons c'est le chômage
un autre problème que nous avons
monsieur juncker là dessus a fait la
bonne analyse c'est le manque
d'investissements et donc il faut qu'on
a reculé en allemagne derrière le mans
nantes en investissement et en faisant
aussi alentours de ce qu'on appelle le
plan joker ce plan relancer
l'investissement en étant très attentif
que cet argent cette mobilisation
financière augmente d'une part
surtout soit concentrée sur les régions
sur les territoires qui en ont le plus
besoin dans des politiques qui soient
les plus pertinentes possibles en terre
de manière à réduire la direction que
vous avez pensé que l' avantage de
monsieur macron sait qu'on sera
peut-être pas au niveau union européenne
comme en france dans une logique
simplement droite gauche
je pense que c'est qui va là même s'il
reste des clivages structurants dans nos
sociétés sont en train de montrer qu'ils
ne sont plus les seuls clivage possible
et je pense qu'il peut y avoir à droite
comme à gauche des idées qui sont
pertinentes
l'objectif c'est quoi c'est bien être
des gens ce n'est pas autre chose car la
sorte à ce que voudrait qu'on regarde
une image qui est donc celle d'un gala
merkel et de françois hollande qui se
sont vus donc pour la dernière fois
lundi soir pour un dîner n'ont pas de
travail mais presque des dieux 1 c'était
donc le dernier déplacement de françois
hollande en tant que président de la
république à la chancelière allemande
quand on entend le les propositions de
emmanuel macron est ce qu'on n'a pas
l'impression en fait que c'est du
hollande c'est de la continuité pur de
ce que françois hollande a pu faire et
donc finalement on n'est même plus dans
le bilan on est dans une forme de
continuité
oui pour eux il faut se souvenir que
françois hollande a été élu avec le
mandat de renégocier le traité
budgétaire mais rien ne s'est passé
après est réussi m croissance dont
traité budget mais qui la mention sur le
concret scénario qu aucune conséquence
mort c'est vrai il ya moi j'ai dit avant
je pense que c'est comme ça il ya un
risque comme evans le maquereau échoue
si jamais il n'y a aucune avancée dans
leur forme d'un zone euro c'est là le
grand enjeu sans doute c'est que la
réforme de la zone euro selon vous
l'enjeu boys à plusieurs enjeux il ya
l'europe sociale et bleu seront jamais
mais la revente d'un euro reste quand
même une question centrale
parce que son budget commun sans
fiscalité commune sans une certaine
coordination du salaire minimum c'est
très très compliqué que la zone euro
puisse fonctionner comme une espèce de
convergence fiscale et sociale en fait
qui fait qu'on s'est sort de la
concurrence entre les sites
d'indispensables en moi ce que j'attends
c'est vrai que d'ici mots le mois de
septembre il ya les élections en
allemagne
ça sera très compliqué de faire bouger
les choses avant les élections ci-après
jamais on a un gouvernement rouge rouge
vers moi je milite pour ça j'aimerais
beaucoup avoir ce scénario parce que bon
quand même le clivage gauche droite ça
représente quelque chose encore
aujourd'hui de mon point de vue si
jamais il ya ça ça sera un scénario
beaucoup plus favorable pour conduisant
vers cette direction
mais c'est vrai moi je pense qu'il
vaudrait attendre sélection allemagne
pour que les choses bougent
alors j'ai entendu madame merkel l'autre
jour en disant bas même hier après
l'élection un nom à toutes les
propositions mais de macron il faut
réformer il faut on va continuer avec
l'austérité
bon je pense aussi qu'un contrat de
confiance aussi à recréant c'est vrai
elle manie c'est vrai et il faut
interpréter les paroles de madame merkel
dans le cadre d'une campagne électorale
qui en faisait en train de survoler ont
également fléchi quand même à la mer
quelques années quand même elle a fait
des progrès elle a fait des efforts sur
vingt réfugiés oui sur les roms la zone
euro aucun web est un réel avenir n est
avancée dans l'année dans la salle
dernières années dormez de cinq
dernières années
on aime jouer les membres location alors
c'est l'heure du checkpoint de cette
émission cette semaine thomas mignon
s'est penché sur une déclaration
justement d' emmanuel macron pendant le
débat de l'entre-deux tours face à
marine le pen il nous a dit la france
serait le dernier europe et pays par
dont la france serait le dernier pays
européen à connaître le chômage de masse
vrai ou faux c'est le checkpoint et
c'est tout de suite le chômage de masse
en europe lors du débat de l'entre-deux
tours emmanuel macron a désigné la
france comme le plus mauvais élève de la
classe européenne
nous sommes dans le chômage de masse
depuis 30 ans nous sommes le seul pays
d'europe n'a pas réussi justement à
endiguer cela alors tout d'abord
qu'est-ce que le chômage de masse il
n'en n'existe pas de définition
scientifique ce concept ne correspond à
aucune unité de mesure dit
l'organisation internationale du travail
qui ne se risque d'ailleurs pas à donner
un quelconque taux au delà duquel on
parlerait de chômage de masse il s'agit
d'une agence d'une notion relative
par exemple en grèce le chômage a
atteint plus de 27 % en 2013
alors si le pays revenaient à un taux de
10% on ne le qualifierais pas de la
sorte alors qu'en allemagne
face à un taux de 10 % on paraît très
certainement de chômage de masse
pourtant cette expression est utilisée
par bon nombre de politiques et reprise
dans de nombreux articles alors en
absence de définition et pour permettre
la comparaison
considérons un instant que ces discours
ont la bonne définition statistiques en
france le taux de chômage moyen de ces
trente dernières années atteint 8,8 pour
cent si cela fait effectivement trente
ans que la france est dans une situation
de chômage de masse on peut se dire que
cela concerne le chômage au-delà de 8%
du moins partant de ce principe lors
qu'elles sont les états membres
concernés par ce soi-disant chômage de
masse sur 28 pays
11 dépasser les 8% de taux de chômage en
2016 quant à la france
le chômage est effectivement à 10% et
parmi les autres pays de l'union qui se
font pire par exemple l'espagne ou
encore l'italie avec respectivement 19 %
et 11 % du coût dire que la france est
le dernier pays de l'union européenne
connaît encore aujourd'hui chômage de
masse c'est tout simplement faux est ce
que c'est le premier enjeu est de bart
en france ce chômage alors qu'il n'est
pas de masse finale en plus on voit que
l'espagne par exemple qu'on l'appelle de
masse ou non c'est pas ça qui importe ce
qui importe ce sont les gens qui ne
trouvent pas d'emploi et ce qui importe
c'est de trouver un emploi de faire en
sorte que l'on crée de l'emploi pour ces
personnes c'est ça l'enjeu primordial et
donc que les gens qui ont un emploi soit
sécurisée sur le fait qu'ils vont garder
cet emploi et ne sont pas eux qui n'est
pas remise en cause c'est ça surtout
parce que cette peur aussi qui est dans
la tête de beaucoup de gens qui ont un
emploi
combien de temps est-ce que cela va
aller mal d'un déclassement voilà et
c'est ça et c'est à cela qu'il faudra
donner une réponse ce drôle hein vous
êtes d'accord
tout à fait d'accord j'ajouterai
éléments ceci dit on est malheureusement
plus dans une société où tout le monde a
un emploi à contrat à durée indéterminée
est donc un autre enjeu pour lutter
contre la précarité pour sécuriser les
gens c'est en gros de sécuriser les
parcours des jeunes référence sera
flexible et korité un peu à la manière
le problème de la vessie sécurité c'est
que jusqu'à présent le monde du travail
n'a jamais eu un aspect flexibilité
ouais donc moi je voudrais bien de la
sécurisation des parcours
professionnel de faire en sorte que
quand les gens ont des trous dans leur
carrière
et bien qu'ils aient de quoi bien vif il
lisait sur tous les moyens de se
recycler de se re situer de retrouver le
plus rapidement possible un emploi à la
sortie
non je veux insister sur l'idée que le
cdr l'emploi dans un pays c'est deux
choses c'est d'avoir des emplois et quel
niveau de qualité d'emploi alors moi je
pense que c'est très important que y ait
un programme pour lutter contre le
chômage en france à travers des
investissements mais surtout que la
solution ne soit pas de précariser le
travail parce qu'on plus vous progressez
votre travail vous allez tuer la poule à
haute productivité par heure travaillée
que vous avez en france qui est un des
grands atouts de votre économie surtout
ne faites pas ça ce serait mon dernier
conseil d'un espagnol qui a vécu la
précarisation du travail et qui est qui
connaît très bien les conséquences que
ceci a pour ses citoyens
oui effectivement va écouter merci
beaucoup en attendant nous avoir éclairé
un sursaut débat on suivra bien entendu
les premiers pas des manuels macro alors
peut-être ici au parlement européen s'il
accepte l'invitation d'antonio tajani
dans les prochaines semaines il ira de
toute façon après son investiture
varangue à la merkel très vite
en général c'est le premier voyage à
l'étranger qui est prévu merci en tout
cas nous on se retrouve la semaine
prochaine à strasbourg
et d'ici là très bonne suite de
programmes très belle semaine à tous
ciao
[Musique]